ces dames gendarmerie nationale
contrôles préventifs sur l'alcoolémie
oui j'ai vous pourriez vous souriez oui
vous savez de quoi il s'agit alors un
bon voulait bien souffrir dans les
cotations
nous concédons un contrôle préventif de
l'imprégnation alcoolique ou les biens
vous soumettre dépistage monsieur louis
bianco docteur langlade a rassuré les
passagers
sinon je sors non nous ne pouvait rester
assis au volant
si monsieur refuse de le soumettre à un
prélèvement sanguin
s'ils refusent le prélèvement sanguin
c'est un délit séquence que les ravines
et cela pour une bière on me dit non
voilà monsieur soufflé fort oui va
souffler
assez fort ce que c'est assez raide tout
surmonté en plastique
[Musique]
voilà ça va ça va ça va commencer c'est
négatif tout ça c'est bon c'est très
bien tomber au labo souple et assez fort
en une seule fois vous conter la poche
ainsi possible voilà ça va ça va ça va
ça va merci à ça chauffe quand on
souffre on sait absolument négatif
est ce que vous êtes favorable de tels
contrôles préventifs
franchement non
à la liberté les gens de boire consommer
ce qu'ils ce qui leur plaît quand il
leur plaît monsieur oui est ce que vous
étiez au courant de cette opération je
savais qu'on avait dans l'est à
saint-denis je crois puisqu'on vient de
paris est ce que vous aviez midi hier
popeye de guerre êtes vous favorable de
tels contrôles
pourquoi quand la liberté
[Musique]